so i'm a bit surprised to see you here
again brady i thought we discussed this
two years ago
is that your time travel joke yeah
and it's before the announcement of the
event right all right
the announcement was last week
well something really amazing has
happened basically because
scientists at saint and in italy have
found that there's a neutrino which is a
certain type of particle that's actually
broken the speed limit it's gone faster
than light the terrible jokes are coming
because of this uh a recent announcement
from this group of experimentalists
based
in italy at the grand sasso laboratory
who've been doing this exp an experiment
for the past three years
where they are looking at neutrinos
flying from
being produced in cern near geneva
flying through the italian alps and and
landing uh going straight through the
detectors at grand sasso but some of
them are interacting with the detectors
and so they've got a good idea of what
time that neutrino left cern and of
course they detect at what time it
arrived in grand sasso and they know the
distance between the two so they just
from that they can work out the speed of
these things and they worked out the
speed and they found out that it was
slightly greater than the speed of light
not by very much
um if you the deviation from the speed
of light so if i say
take the velocity of the neutrinos
subtract from it the velocity of light
and divide by the velocity of light so
it's got no no dimensions that number is
10 to the minus five so it's one part in
a hundred thousand so it sounds
negligible and everybody should say well
okay so it is the speed of light then
but
they they they believe their statistics
are so good
that um
it could well be that it's a real effect
i mean you just think how fast these
things are going right so
they're going so quickly to notice any
time difference at all you know you've
got to sort of have them travel over a
very large distance so i mean these
things are only you know i think it's
they've arrived 60 nanoseconds faster
than light would have done okay so
that's a tiny tiny tiny tiny time scale
and yet they still traveled over 730
kilometers to be fair to the
experimentalists
they themselves are skeptical i think
that you can tell by the fact that the
the way they've announced the results
the the paper that they've put out on
the archive for everyone to see they
openly say this is strange we don't
understand why it's
this result is there but we've tried
everything we can to account for all the
areas that might bring it back within
the speed of light so that the neutrinos
are going
at the speed of light or slightly less
and they can't find any reason why they
are okay so i guess most people's first
impression is that you know this is this
is almost too incredible to be true and
certainly that's that's probably true of
most scientists but of course you know
if something happens we have to look
into it and actually look very closely
at what's going on one of the first
thing you might say is have they got say
the distance between the source and the
detector right have they measured it
correctly and but they've used very
sophisticated gps that kind of thing and
it seems that they can get the distance
right to within 20 centimeters so this
really and taking into account the
earth's rotation taking taking into
account sort of you know movement of the
earth's crust all this kind of thing you
know all this has gone into it to work
out this distance very very very
precisely and actually the consensus
does seem to be that a distance
calculation is is right that there's
there's really nothing wrong there
there's slightly more
there's many more concerns really
regarding the the time
okay so again they have to measure the
the time of departure in a time of
arrival and they have to measure it very
accurately now they claim they can get
the the time of flight accurate to
within about 10 nanoseconds and given
that the time difference is 60
nanoseconds they're like okay that's
good enough and so they've basically put
it out to the community they've pleaded
for another experiment to be done
and as it happens there are two
experiments that could be done to test
this
both also firing neutrinos long
distances
and that's i suppose the plan now that
these two experiments will
which are already underway we'll we'll
we'll try and home in on this uh
particular result let's just let's let's
just assume it's true right i mean it's
more exciting if it is right so
what's going on okay well
you've got to really understand sort of
quite how groundbreaking this is now you
know in einstein's relativity
the speed of light is there is the
maximum speed that you know any normal
particle can go at you know you can't
accelerate beyond the speed of light the
reason you can't is as you as you
approach the speed of light
your mass becomes infinite and so you
know you need an infinite amount of
energy to go beyond that speed
that's true of most particles right
there is a certain type of particle
which can go beyond the speed of light
it's it's called a tachyon you may have
heard that word sort of touted around in
the last week uh basically this is a
particle whose mass
is actually imaginary so if it's got
imaginary mass that means that like an
imaginary number is something like the
square root of minus one or the square
root of minus two so this is this is a
mass which is the square root of
something negative
so these are very peculiar particles in
any sort of quantum theory we normally
associate them with with horrendous
instability so we we we
we don't like them but
if you prepare if you're prepared to
accept that that they might exist then
they would travel fast and light but
with very profound consequences actually
um one of the consequences is that you
could potentially go send signals back
in time
so one possibility is that it's a
tachyon and that you can send signals
back in time and that you can kill your
grandfather before you were born and all
even before he was born you know and all
those paradoxes associated with that
the other possibility of course is
other exotic things that there's no such
exotic idea of time travel or anything
like that but perhaps this is
this neutrino is passing through an
extra dimension it's taking a shortcut
through an extra dimension so if you
like it's like traveling from uh london
to to australia but rather than going
around the sort of two-dimensional
surface of the earth you burrow through
the center and take take a shortcut
through the escort it's kind of like
that idea
another possibility is that
um the neutrinos
are seeing like a different geometry so
the thing that controls the maximum
speed
is really the geometry of your space
time
okay
so
if everything else sees one particular
geometry and the neutrino sees another
geometry then the rules of the game for
the neutrino are different to the rules
of game for everything else i'm a little
bit skeptical uh i think
having i've but i'm a theorist so i'm
very excited but i think uh
it's time to
sit back and look
um
in a lot more detail at their analysis
um which is kind of out of my league to
do that but i've i've read the paper
i've listened to the talk it's clear
from reading the paper it's a really
difficult experiment
i think the most people's reaction tends
to be to dismiss it immediately
sometimes a bit too readily i think
i mean i i
i'm a bit different and i'm a sort of
eternal optimist and so you know when
these kind of results come out i get
very excited about it but uh you know as
i said i'm the eternal optimist i i
always started every season i think
liverpool are gonna be in the league so
it probably says something more about me
than uh
than about my colleagues i mean what one
of the reasons i is
because i don't if you don't only think
about the particle physics if you think
about the astrophysics there are other
reasons why you
you'd have to treat this
bit of data at the moment with a degree
of skepticism so in astrophysics we know
about supernovae okay now in 1987 a
supernova went off in fact i was at
fermilab when the supernovae went off
well it had gone off years before but we
detected it we know that with those
supernovae neutrinos and light
arrived within three hours of each other
now
and that was that's perfectly well
understood because in a supernovae the
neutrinos are emitted as soon as the
core collapses
so they begin their process their
journey straight away almost the light
doesn't emit until the shock wave is
bounced and then the light can escape
and there's like a three-hour difference
and that
assuming they both went at the speed of
light that accounted perfectly for this
difference if this result holds
and it and it holds for all the
neutrinos then we would have expected to
see
the burst of neutrinos three and a half
years earlier
because the neutrinos were growing that
much faster and there was no evidence of
any neutrinos arriving three and a half
years earlier your non-physicist friends
who you might go to the pub with do they
ask you about this one this is
definitely one that's cropped up yeah
yeah yeah so um
actually one of them one of them told me
a joke about it so i might as well tell
that joke
so the joke is that the um the barman
goes oh we don't serve new trudeau's in
here
and then the neutrino walks into the bar
so
i'm blaming him for that joke but uh
probably he probably shouldn't give him
his day job
i don't really believe this thing's a
tachyon and uh if it turns out it is a
tachyon i'll go back in time and not do
this video so if you're watching this
video that's proof that this thing's not
not attacking